le plugin ses doigts daigneault est
moche tu parles de ta gueule est-ce que
je te parles de ta gueule quand un
casting je fais ça et dès que j'ai
tourné ma tête tu commets pas contrarier
repaître je veux rien faire
toi tu es vraiment trop craquant quoi la
mode des musées aggrave donc là tu
regardes a ici et tu fais e gignac est
là je pense qu'il faut en faire la seule
balle de break avec l'expert grecque ne
s'était pas tu as dit à tes sweatshops
[ __ ] mais plus de mères moi je
verrouille et la même potentiellement
soyez potentiellement vie
à quoi tendent et est magnifique
voilà lesquels
les tornades mecredi cerveau pastiche
est beau les gens prennent leurs jambes
comme ça
k
ça sonnait plus tôt possible de
s'adonner à des cloques alors voilà
grecque alors par contre pourrait
pousser du chant éventuellement que je
fais quoi c'est bénéfique ou non mais y
aller ça dure
cette chambre ok je me trouve s'est tu
avais trop misé at il pas normal c'est
un peu moi j'attends quelques jeux super
de pringles de l'ordre à la vie de
beethoven jeter doit actuellement je
dois le paquet pringles widgery
d'algérie excuse moi mais c'est pas ton
téléphone que je suis en fait les gars
là c'était trop de doutes terme en
autiste
akimbo c'est pas mal beckham
enfin quand je dis à tes souhaits des
veaux direct sur sa de sa bouche et
m
waouh
à